les ingénieurs ayant étudié l'ingénierie.
En vérité, ces gens ne sont plus la règle
mais sont l'exception.
Une étude de 2010 a révélé qu'un quart des diplômés universitaires
travaille dans un domaine en lien avec leur diplôme.
J'ai non pas un mais deux diplômes en biologie.
Au désarroi de mes parents, je ne suis ni médecin ni scientifique.
(Rires)
Les années d'études en réplication de l'ADN et de la photosynthèse
ne m'ont pas préparé à une carrière dans la technologie.
J'ai dû tout apprendre tout seul : la vente, le marketing, la stratégie
et même un peu de programmation.
Je n'avais jamais eu le poste de chef de produit
avant d'avoir envoyé mon CV à Etsy.
J'avais déjà été rejeté par Google et d'autres entreprises
et j'étais frustré.
L'entreprise était récemment devenue publique
et, pour ma candidature,
j'avais lu l'introduction en bourse d'un bout à l'autre
et créé entièrement un site incluant mon analyse de l'entreprise
et quatre nouvelles idées.
Il s'est avéré que l'équipe travaillait activement sur deux de ces idées
et en avait considéré une troisième.
J'ai obtenu le poste.
Nous connaissons tous des gens ayant été ignorés ou négligés au début
mais qui ont progressé et démenti les critiques.
Mon histoire préférée ?
Brian Acton, un responsable en ingénierie,
qui a été rejeté par Twitter et Facebook
avant de cofonder WhatsApp,
la plateforme de messagerie mobile vendue à 19 milliards de dollars.
Les systèmes d'embauche établis au XXe siècle sont défaillants
et nous font passer à côté de gens ayant un potentiel incroyable.
Les avancées en robotique et apprentissage de la machine
changent notre façon de travailler,
automatisant des tâches routinières dans beaucoup d'emplois
tout en augmentant et amplifiant la main d’œuvre humaine dans d'autres.
A ce rythme, nous devrions nous attendre à faire des travaux jamais vus avant
durant le reste de notre carrière.
Quels sont les outils et les stratégies nécessaires
pour identifier les gens très performants demain ?
A la recherche de réponses, j'ai contacté des dirigeants dans de nombreux secteurs,
lu des douzaines de rapports et d'articles de recherche
et conduit mes propres tests de talent.
Ma quête est loin d'être finie
mais voici les trois idées que j'aimerais avancer.
Un : étendez votre recherche.
En ne cherchant du talent que dans les endroits habituels --
les programmes pour surdoués, les grandes écoles,
les organisations prestigieuses --
nous allons obtenir les mêmes résultats que d'habitude.
Le baseball a été transformé quand les Athletics d'Oakland, à court d'argent,
ont recruté des joueurs n'ayant pas de scores élevés
sur les métriques traditionnelles, comme les points,
mais qui avaient la capacité d'aider l'équipe à marquer des points
et faire gagner des matchs.
Cette idée se développe en dehors du sport.
Le chef du design et de la recherche de Pinterest
m'a dit qu'ils avaient créé l'une des équipes
les plus diverses et performantes de Silicon Valley
car ils croyaient qu'aucun type de personne
n'avait le monopole du talent.
Ils ont cherché au-delà des centres technologiques majeurs
et se sont concentrés sur les portfolios
et non les pedigrees des designers.
Deux : embauchez pour la performance.
Inspiré de ma propre expérience professionnelle,
j'ai cofondé une plateforme de recrutement, Headlight,
qui donne aux candidats l'opportunité de briller.
Comme les équipes ont des essais et les pièces des auditions,
les candidats devraient démontrer leurs compétences
avant d'être embauchés.
Nos clients bénéficient de 85 ans de recherche en recrutement,
qui montre que les exercices
sont l'un des meilleurs indicateurs de réussite au travail.
Pour un analyste de données,
donnez leur un tableau avec d'anciennes données et demandez-lui les idées clés.
Pour un responsable en marketing,
il planifie une campagne de lancement d'un produit.
Si vous êtes un candidat, n'attendez pas que l'employeur demande.
Cherchez des moyens de mettre en avant vos compétences et capacités uniques
en dehors du CV et de la lettre de motivation standards.
Trois : cherchez la vision d'ensemble.
Certains recruteurs classifient vite un candidat comme instable
du fait d'une mission courte sur son CV ;
certains professeurs ont tendance d'ignorer un même message d'un étudiant
car son nom trahissait une origine noire ou asiatique plutôt que blanche.
Enfant, j'ai presque été qualifié comme ayant des besoins spéciaux.
Après un mois de maternelle,
mon professeur a écrit un mot
notant que j'étais impulsif,
avait une capacité d'attention limitée
et malgré ma curiosité merveilleuse,
il était épuisant de travailler avec moi.
(Rires)
Le directeur a demandé un rendez-vous à mes parents,
demandé à ma mère s'il y avait eu des complications à la naissance
et suggéré que je rencontre un psychologue scolaire.
Mon père a vu ce qu'il se passait
et a rapidement expliqué notre situation familiale.
En tant qu'immigrants récents, nous vivions dans le grenier
d'une maison de soins pour adultes handicapés mentaux.
Me parents travaillaient à joindre les deux bouts
et j'avais peu d'opportunités de passer du temps avec des enfants de mon âge.
Est-ce surprenant qu'un garçon de cinq ans manquant de stimulation
soit un peu excité dans la classe de maternelle
après un été entier tout seul ?
Avant d'avoir une vision holistique de quelqu'un,
notre jugement sera toujours erroné.
Arrêtons d'égaler l'expérience et la capacité,
les qualifications et la compétence.
Arrêtons de nous contenter du choix sûr et familier
et laissons la porte ouverte à quelqu'un pouvant être génial.
Les employeurs doivent laisser tomber les pratiques de recrutement désuètes
et embrasser de nouvelles façons d'identifier et de cultiver le talent
et les candidats peuvent aider en apprenant à raconter leur histoire
avec passion et conviction.
Nous pourrions vivre dans un monde où les gens sont vus pour leur potentiel
et ont l'opportunité de réaliser leur plein potentiel.
Allons bâtir ce monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)